(upbeat instrumental music)
- Good afternoon to everyone.
My name is Dylan Riley and
I'm a Professor of Sociology
in the Department of
Sociology here at Berkeley
and a member of the Bernard
Moses Lectureship committee.
We are of course enormously
pleased and excited
to present Arlie Hochschild,
this year's speaker
at the Bernard Moses Memorial
Lecture series this afternoon
and before presenting Professor Hochschild
I'm just gonna describe a little bit
about what this lecture series is about.
It's part of the obligation of the quest.
But he's a very interesting person so.
In 1937 a University
of California president
Robert Gordon Sproul, Sproul Plaza,
and the UC Board of Regents established
the Bernard Moses Memorial Lectureship
in the Social Sciences.
The Lectureship honors the
memory of Bernard Moses
who was a professor of history
and political science at Berkeley.
He was a kind of universal intellectual.
He wrote books ranging from
studies of constitutionalism
in Latin America to Swiss democracy
to the rise of the German
empire in the late 19th Century
and he was a professor at the University
from 1875 to 1911 and then Emeritus
from 1911 until 1930 when he died.
Under worldwide reputation
for his various contributions
and really in a way for establishing
the tradition of comparative
politics at Berkeley.
The lecture series has
featured in the recent past
such eminent speakers as Herma Hill Kay,
Nicholas Riasanovsky, George Lakoff,
Kenneth Stampp, Carolyn Merchant,
Jean Lave, Emmanuel Saez,
Mary Ann Mason and Sociology's
very own Ann Swidler.
But now I'd like to turn to our speaker
for this afternoon,
Professor Arlie Hochschild.
Professor Hochschild is a distinguished,
really eminent American sociologist.
Her most recent work that
she's gonna be speaking
about today explores the
experiences, beliefs,
and deep story of the American right,
obviously a very timely matter
and this is encapsulated in her book
Strangers in Their Own Land:
Anger and Mourning on the American Right.
This text was based on
five years of research
in Louisiana's oil and petrochemical belt.
So if you go out into the
delta of the Mississippi River
this is where these things are located
where she interviewed
Tea Party enthusiasts.
The book was a New York Times' best-seller
and it was a finalist as well
for the National Book Award.
This latest book sort of
culminates an incredibly
impressive career with such great titles
as The Time Bind, The Second Shift,
The Managed Heart, So How's
the Family and Other Essays,
The Outsource Itself, and Global Women.
Her publications has been
translated into 16 languages
and she has contributed to
efforts in global feminist
community programs and
she has also written
a children's story entitled
Colleen the Question Girl.
I'd like to just say a couple of words
about Professor Hochschild
as a sociologist
before turning the floor over to her.
I would say that really kind of as a group
sociologists are generally
characterized by two traits.
One is that they're terrible writers
and the other is that they
have a kind of a penchant
for inventing totally
unnecessary terminology
to describe the obvious.
What I think is really admirable
about Professor Hochschild's
work is it's complete break
with both of these
traditions in the discipline.
As anyone who's looked
at this most recent book
or any of her work knows
she's a great prose writer.
Very rare in our discipline.
And second, the concepts
that she brings to bear
on her analyses, emotional
labor, second shift,
deep story, not only
encapsulate and reveal
underlying elements of social reality
that we wouldn't have seen before,
they are often in fact reincorporated
into our social imagination in a way
that's really only comparable
to the great sociologist
Robert Merton with his concept
such as self-fulfilling
prophesy and so on.
So really an unusual scholar
and a truly great sociologist
and it's really my pleasure to welcome
Professor Arlie Hochschild
to the Moses Lecture
series this afternoon.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Well what a great pleasure to be here.
You know actually I House
was the very first building
I stepped into almost trembling
as a first year graduate
student here at Berkeley
and I stayed here for my first month.
I actually even have a small
box that says I House on it
which contained all my
worldly possessions.
So here I am again.
So what I thought I'd try and do today
is first take you with me on a journey
that I've returned from,
tell you the question I went in with,
but the findings I came out with
and then share with you some
of the responses I've had
to The Second Shift and then deal with
kind of one of the fundamental
questions that I think
the book raises of the efficacy,
the wisdom, the capacity
to reach over the growing
partisan divide in this country today.
Can we do it?
Is it worth doing?
What happens and what would
be the result of that?
So let me begin by saying
that I started in 2011
realizing that I, Berkeley,
now my home all these years,
I was living in a
political and moral bubble.
It was a geographic bubble.
You know from this book The Big Sort
that when people move it's increasingly
not for better, cheaper
housing and better jobs
but for compatibility,
cultural and political.
And I also found myself in a media bubble.
I read The New York Times religiously
and an electronic bubble
the way all of us are
our computers give us back
to ourselves as you know
algorithmically and I didn't know anyone
that would be suspicious say of a word
like international here,
International House,
or would think that
Berkeley and things public,
public universities and parks were suspect
and that even the government itself
was more a problem than solution.
I didn't know anyone like that
and turned out I wasn't alone.
A recent Pew study showed that
nearly half, 47% of people
who planned to vote for Hillary Clinton
didn't have any close friends
who were Trump supporters
and same number say that
if a friend supported Trump
it would put a strain on their friendship.
So in fact democrats turn
out to be substantially
less able to countenance
friends who support
the quote wrong candidates.
Just 13% of republicans
say a friend's support
of Hillary Clinton would
strain their relationship.
So many reasons for that imbalance
but I was in some strange
way kind of relieved
okay I wasn't the only one.
So I decided you know what?
I'm gonna try and find a
bubble that's as far right
as the sociology department
at Berkeley, California
in the blue state of California is left.
I thought well where would that be?
That would be in the south
where we know the right
has risen the fastest and strongest.
But where in the south?
Well how about the super south?
And I discovered that 2012
looking at the proportion
of whites who voted for Barack Obama
in the whole region of
the south, 13 states,
it was a third but in
Louisiana it was 14%.
So I thought perfect,
okay, let's go there.
And let's within Louisiana
there is a region where
the petrochemical industry
is concentrated and as luck would have it
I had one contact who was through a former
graduate student of mine in sociology.
His mother-in-law lived in
a town called Lake Charles
so I started there not thinking
that this would be more
than a taster of just
seeing what it felt like,
wasn't sure it was a book yet.
And I brought with me The Paradox.
How many have read the book?
Cause I don't wanna repeat too much.
Okay, alright.
Good I asked.
The Paradox was the red state paradox
that how could it be
that the poorest states,
the states with the worst
schools and hospitals,
the most road accidents,
the lowest life expectancy,
worst health, most pollution,
are also the states
that receive more money
from the federal government
in aid than they give to it in tax dollars
and revile the federal government?
That was the red state
paradox and Louisiana
was an exaggerated version of that.
Second poorest state,
44% of its state budget
came from the federal
government and super tea party
very right wing and in the
end extremely enthusiastic
about Donald Trump.
I also discovered that as
I kind of sniffed the air
around Lake Charles and
went over the I-10 bridge
to West Lake, this is
in southwest Louisiana
and petrochemical plants all around
my eyes would begin to
sting and the sky was
like it is today and there was
people all had bottled water.
So I thought wait a minute.
Something is talking to me.
Maybe the environment is
what I should look at,
this pollution, because
people in Louisiana
that I came to know were
adamantly against regulating
any kind of industry
including the polluters.
So they were living in one
of the most polluted spots
in the entire world and
they're opposed to pollution.
I thought this is my keyhole issue.
Let me just look at that
and get to know people.
Well five years later,
50 interviews later,
over 4,000 pages of transcript later,
I came to realize that the
question I had come with
was my question.
People would respond to
it by saying yeah, yeah,
we know about the red state paradox.
It's an embarrassment to us.
They knew about it.
They lived with it.
But they set it aside.
Knowledgeable about it,
so it wasn't a question
of not knowing.
It was a question of its
not being the main point.
So I thought well if
that's one thing I learned.
The low importance
attributed to this question.
But as I got to know people
I began to realize that values,
the way values expressed themselves,
the way values value is by
making a story feel true
and the way circumstances
really imprint themselves
is again the way it makes people
believe a story to be true.
So I made up a story that
I thought fit everything
I was hearing over that period of time.
And what is a deep story?
Deep story is a story that feels true.
It's described by the objective
correlative of feelings
that is it's what all the
details you believe to be true
that account for why
you feel what you feel.
You feel mourning.
You feel lost.
You feel envy.
You feel anger.
And those are told in the story
which to refresh you goes like this
and by the way all of us
have underneath our political
beliefs a deep story.
You're waiting in line
and your feel are pointed
toward the top of a hill as in a dream
tells itself by metaphor
and you see at the top
the American dream and you
don't see anything behind it
that's causing changes in it.
You just see the distance
between you and it.
You're not looking
behind you in line either
and the line hasn't moved.
People hadn't had a raise in two decades
and they were tired.
They were in their fifties and sixties.
This was it.
Life was narrowing down.
And then they notice
someone cutting ahead.
Well who's that?
Well that would be blacks
finally through federally
mandated affirmative action
plans given access to jobs
that have historically
been reserved for whites
and even worse, women
who now through federally
mandated affirmative action
are finally given jobs
that have historically
been reserved for men.
I'm an example.
So these line cutters and then
we would have undocumented
workers and even for them
the oil-soaked brown pelican,
Louisiana's state bird,
seems to be cutting in line.
People told me time and time again.
Oh those liberal environmentalists
put animals ahead of people.
Animists.
And then another moment of
the right wing deep story
looks like Barack Obama
who should be the impartial
supervisor of this line, this country,
seems to be waving to the line cutter.
Oh he's their president.
He doesn't see us.
In fact isn't he a line cutter?
And here was a little paranoid
streak that would kick in.
Oh, how did his mother, poor woman,
not a woman of, not wealthy,
afford a Harvard education?
A Columbia education?
Something fishy.
Something rigged.
Would come after that observation.
No such thing as scholarships
for brilliant students.
So it's rigged.
So another moment of the
right wing deep story
someone from the coast,
maybe from Berkeley,
maybe a woman, would get up
and was way ahead in line
and turn back and say
oh, you to the person
waiting in line who's been there forever,
you homophobic, racist,
sexist, fat redneck
and that was the word,
redneck, that you could
almost see it was a tipping point term
of I've been dissociated.
I have been non-personed.
I am a stranger in my own land.
I've worked this hard,
working hard and so on,
serving the American dream.
Redneck kind of cast them adrift
and of course the
environment wasn't theirs.
They didn't feel like
the culture was theirs.
They didn't feel like religion,
they were highly religious
and they felt growth of secularism
and as whites they saw the
country changing its complexion
and they felt that even the
bayou they looked out on
they couldn't swim in, they
couldn't eat the fish from.
It wasn't theirs either.
So there was a moment of estrangement
and strangerness and
actually a later study,
a survey found that those
who answered yes in a poll
that they felt like strangers
in their own country,
this was Atlantic, a study,
were three and a half times
more likely to vote for Donald Trump
and I felt that the end of my odyssey
Donald Trump was coming for the first time
to a primary rally in New Orleans
and he hadn't won the primary.
He was just coming.
But in Louisiana this was the next day
and seeing the crowd,
seeing the excitement
and here he comes down from the sky
in the Donald Trump plane, you know almost
like descended from heaven right?
And he was the emotions candidate.
Look how emotional we are.
We're not the silent majority.
We're the noisy majority.
And he promised in essence
he hit the theme of loss.
They did feel they had lost something.
He hit that and he hit the theme of blame,
who to blame for the loss.
That would be the line cutters.
And he hit the theme of uplift and rescue.
Great again.
Was almost I came to feel
like a secular rapture.
Well I'm gonna take you
up to heaven with me.
And in fact if you look
at some of the pictures
of the top floor of Trump Tower
it looked very much like
people's description of heaven.
Everything was gold.
(audience laughing)
So I concluded, came
home scratching my head
and saying look I started
with this red state paradox
but really I'm going home
with a blue state paradox.
How could it be that the democratic party,
the party of the working
man and the working women,
did not speak to them.
I didn't see any glimmer in their eye
with regard to Hillary's candidacy.
How could this be?
Some of them, by the way, had nice things
to say about Bernie Sanders.
Extremely right wing tea
party people would say
oh Uncle Bernie.
Uncle Bernie.
Well he's a socialist.
We're a capitalist country and
he's promising pie in the sky
but friendly feeling.
He means well.
So I came home with
the blue state paradox.
Now what I'd like to share with you today
is what some of the responses
to the book have been.
I've been on another
odyssey with regard to that.
I went home and when the
book came out the next week
I sent out copies of it to the people
that I'd written about who had helped me
and I went back to Louisiana
put a dinner on for them,
another one for the people
I dedicated the book to
and one of the characters,
Janice Serrino if you've read,
she was the company
loyalist and very tough
and she came to the dinner with a jacket
and she came up to me
and said you wanna see
what I have on under my jacket?
Yeah.
So she pulled it open and it
said adorable deplorables.
I'm gonna send you one of these.
(audience laughing)
But you have to wear it.
No promises.
So they liked the
description of themselves.
In fact this Janice would say
Arlie you have a swear word in my chapter.
Your chapter?
She felt proprietary about her chapter.
Well I did have a swear word
there but it was quoting
Sher Bono who has a transgender child
and who was complaining
about the F tea party.
So I had that in there in order to account
for Janice Serino, my
respondent's hatred of Hollywood
but that was, nevermind, she didn't want
the swear word in her chapter.
Did they read appendix C
which had all the facts
that were taken out of the deep story?
No.
I began receiving letters on my email
from people across the country
and they give you, let me
share one with you here.
This is from a young man, 23.
He began I live 15 miles outside
a small one stoplight town
of 2,500 in rural Virginia.
I've lived here in Gretna
for all 23 years of my life
save for the four years I spent
at the University of Virginia.
Half a mile deep in the
woods behind my house
is an abandoned grave of a 19
year old Confederate private.
I found it one day when I was hunting.
I was 19 myself at the
time and standing there
with a rifle in my hand I
had to reckon with that.
What was really the
difference between me and him
in that very moment except for the time
in which fate placed us?
Fields that were once full
of tobacco now go unplanted.
Old plantation homes lie in despair.
The furniture plant where
my grandfather worked
has closed down.
The textile mill where
by grandmother worked
has been bulldozed down.
The jobs outsourced overseas.
At the end he thanks me for listening
and then wonders if he should come
to the sociology department at Berkeley.
(audience laughing)
An older woman writes I'm
writing from our farm house
in Fairview, Kansas.
I was sewing this afternoon and listening
to a Canadian podcast from
2016 and a grace video
in which you discuss the state
of people across America.
You know the number of dairies around here
has dropped dramatically over the years.
The larger dairies employ a
couple of high school boys
to work morning and evenings.
The boys go to work at three a.m.
And after work they stop
at Casey's for biscuits
and gravy and bring with
them to school to eat
before the tardy bell rings at eight.
She goes on.
Thanks me for listening.
And wants to set up a high
school exchange program.
A middle-aged woman writes I'm
from northeastern Kentucky.
Appalachia is the sister
area to Louisiana.
I came to Christ in the
Methodist church as a child
and during the charismatic
renewal in the 1960s
my mother started going
to a Pentecostal church.
My walk with God is personal every day
and outside of the physical church.
My problem as a Christian is this.
I find myself on the outside
of the Christian church
because of the politics that consumes it.
Thanks for listening.
One more.
As a female Indian Muslim,
another young woman writes,
living in a conservative part of America,
I often felt disliked
and discriminated against
which led to my hatred of
many of those in my community.
Reading your book has
changed my perspective
and made it easier to share my beliefs
to help create understanding
and feel more understanding
towards those I once disregarded.
One more.
I hail from Lake Charles, Louisiana.
My brother works at the
company formerly known
as Pittsburgh Plate Glass,
central to many of my stories,
and lives under the
chlorine cloud in the shadow
cast by the cranes building
Sessel in West Lake.
I was surrounded by the
milieu you capture so well.
It's been hard to read your book,
very hard to read your book,
but I thank you for it.
Now I've been very
moved by these responses
and it's raised for me a question
about reaching out to
heal this partisan divide
or as I describe in the book
climb an empathy wall
across this partisan divide.
Now there are people
who say you know what?
That's a fool's errand.
There was a review of this book.
It was respectful but
really took a different line
by Frank Rich in New York
Magazine this last spring
in which he said you know what?
Don't waste your empathy.
We need anger and it's
a waste of time to talk
to any of these people and
someone I very much respect
normally and Katha Pollitt
again in The Nation
takes a very respectful
but she said really
hold on to your anger.
Don't waste any breath.
And that got me to the place where I am
just speaking personally
to that very question
of the efficacy of reaching
across this growing divide.
The way I see it at this
frightening political
moment is that we have three
possible pillars of activism.
First one is to address our attention,
all our action, toward the defense
of the principle of checks and balances.
Independent press, a revered
and independent judiciary,
so that no president would
put himself above the law.
This I think is number
one and you don't need
to talk to anyone who disagrees with you
to pursue pillar one.
Pillar two for me would be to turn
to the democratic platform
which does not speak
to the people I came to
know and those like them
and to engage in electoral politics.
And again, you wouldn't
need to talk to anyone
you disagree with to engage pillar two.
And then there's pillar
three and you can say
well look, I don't wanna
talk to the hard core
neo-Nazis we saw in Charles' film
and I'm with you in that.
But if we think about
what by some estimates
are eight and a half
million people who voted
for Barack Obama in 2012 and
then switched to Donald Trump
in 2016 we do wanna talk to some of them.
Or if you look at the, by some estimates,
one out of three, other
estimates one out of four
high school educated blue collar whites
who would have voted for
Bernie Sanders if he had
been the Democratic candidate but instead
voted for someone else,
majority for Trump,
would they be of interest?
And once you selected
who it is you thought
it would be interesting to
climb the empathy wall with
how would you do it?
And why would you do it?
My thought is that these three pillars
need to be coordinated with each other
if you really want to revamp a platform
you better know what the
response to it would be
and if you want to defend
really the whole principle
of checks and balances that
underlies our democracy
you better know how people see it
and how they feel about it so that these
should be coordinated
and like in the British
sort of loyal opposition
kind of coordinated
and acting in unison.
So you don't have to talk
to people you disagree with.
You don't need to climb that empathy wall.
But what you do need to do I believe
is see the reason for doing it
and the reason for doing it I think
is two fold.
One is moral.
I felt again in the mail I'm getting
a lot of moral sort of
wish to heal this divide.
Another quote a woman
wrote that she was part
of an Episcopal church in Massachusetts
and she wanted to get in
touch with the congregation
in Lake Charles and did
I know of a parishioner
that she could contact?
Well as luck had it, I did.
Called my Louisiana friend
up and they are now in touch.
And so if you got together with someone
how would you do it and in
what way would you do it?
Would you just get there and
say here's what I believe.
I think is true and
you've got a deep story
and it's not true.
(audience laughing)
Or would you say different as we are,
maybe there are strips of common
ground on particular issues
and those issues could be
getting money out of politics.
They could be reducing prison populations.
They could be alternative
energy to something
called the green tea party.
Did you know that?
They're tea party people
for alternative energy.
Check it out.
Deborah Dooley now in Florida.
So strips of common ground.
so I'm not envisioning one
kind of right wing moderate
getting together with one kind
of left wing moderate morphing.
That's one model for talking.
But there's also possibility
when you completely disagree
on basic principles but yet
the discourse of respect
and empathic basis.
I went back to one man,
this one who was very
enthusiastic tea party.
He was born on a sugar
plantation in the old south.
He worked in oil all his adult life
and he was big tea party and Trump.
Name was Mike and last time I went back
I was with my son who was
a big environmentalist.
I was trying to see if they
could come to common ground
on ending pollution and my son asked him
well Mike, do you have any
hesitations about Donald Trump?
And if you looked at Mike's Facebook
it was just all flags and Trump.
But he answered in a spirit of openness
where do I begin?
So a lot is in the very
spirit you establish
of mutual respect across deep differences.
The other is what I think
of as simple stretching.
I just did an op-ed for The
Washington Post on this.
What is a symbol stretch?
It's when you notice what the symbols are
of the person you're talking to
and you nod to that
symbol but you stretch it
to something they're not thinking about.
I followed around an extraordinary man
named General Russel Honore
who is a three star general
and was the rescuer of the victims
of Katrina in New Orleans.
He's now an ardent environmentalist
and he goes around talking to people
who don't agree with
him on the environment.
I was there watching
him when he was talking
to some very conservative
businessmen in Lake Charles.
And their talk was all about freedom.
The freedom to start your own business.
The freedom to get as rich as you want.
The freedom from big heavy
government regulations.
Freedom.
And so this general got up and he said
I woke up this morning and
I looked out at Lake Charles
and I saw a man in a boat and
he had his fishing line out
and he had his bucket ready.
But that man is not free to
lift out an uncontaminated fish.
I thought you genius.
You just stretched the symbol of freedom
over to something they
hadn't thought about.
And I followed him
around wherever he went.
See how he stretched symbols.
So their way is kind of
the skills of the mediator
that we can use.
There is actually for all
of the focus on a growing
partisan divide and increasing bitterness
and brittleness consolidation of each pole
under an extremely divisive
leadership shall we say
a grass roots movement of bridging
and if you were to
Google tonight something
called the Bridge Alliance
you would find some 70 or 80
different small organizations
with funny names
like hi from the other side
or living room conversations
which was started
by Joan Blades, the
co-founder of MoveOn.org
here in Berkeley.
She's a labor mediator by training
that bring left and right to see
if they can find common
ground on particular issues.
There is a Bridge Berkeley
and one of the young men in it
by the name of John Rider, John, no
has tried to get left and right together
on climate change and actually
he and I were emailing
and I was in Baton Rouge.
He said oh, what are you
doing in Baton Rouge?
I said well I'm giving a talk.
He says I'm in Dallas.
Well what are you doing in Dallas?
He was getting left and right together
to see if there could be
common ground on that.
So it made me proud that he was Berkeley
and that he was part of
Berkeley Bridge Movement
and that he was trying
for putting pillar three
in its larger perspective
but trying to be active in it.
I think at its best you see Berkeley
hatches students like John
and a place like International
House which is out looking,
out reaching to people in other countries
that that very spirit
Berkeley could be a leader
in extending to the strangers among us
within this home country.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Okay so we have about 10
minutes to have questions
and I would just urge
you to try to formulate
your question concisely and to make sure
that it's an actual question.
(audience laughing)
The mic is down front in the center.
- That was a great talk, thanks.
A lot of thought-provoking things there.
I've been an activist for some 30 years.
I lived in this house at one point.
I guess you were addressing
mostly federal issues.
We could talk about many things.
We live in the sixth largest economy
here in this day.
- We live in a what?
Sorry.
- The sixth largest economy in the state
so when the California
legislature makes decisions
it can really affect the country
and the world in many ways.
So my recommendation to people is to learn
their assembly person
and their state senator
and make calls and what
do you say to that?
Is there a lot of room
to affect change through
at the state level we were established
as a federal system.
People have forgotten
that and we often are only
looking at the national government.
But isn't there a lot to
be done at state levels?
- There is a lot to be proud
of in this California state
and a lot we can do as
Californians to reach out.
I just learned of an
app that will tell you
any particular day in what state
what bill is coming up and
what friend in your Facebook
pack of friends lives in that state
and it was probably Silicon
Valley that invented it.
- I've tried a strategy
that hasn't been successful
so I'd like your comment.
So my feeling is that of all the issues
that the left has
which is dozens of issues
they should focus on income inequality
and not care about gun control,
even immigration, even abortion.
I advise everybody to just
pay Planned Parenthood a lot.
But people are so wedded to their issues
that they're not giving up.
What do I do?
- So your proposal is that
all of us pick one main issue.
That is a hugely primary issue.
It's the issue of a
sinking bottom, of poverty
and loss of democracy.
This is a Bernie Sanders issue.
My thought would be to hold
there are many issues and
I think race is a big issue
and it underlies the inequality.
It's connected with class.
So I would put those two things,
inequality, class, and race
primary, I guess, yeah.
- Hi, thank you for your talk.
I'm wondering, in terms of--
- A little louder.
- Louder.
Closer to the mic, how's that?
Finding the strips of common
ground that you mentioned.
What about the more general
shared common humanity
of wanting to be happy,
not wanting to suffer?
Caring about our families
that aren't political.
That aren't charged.
- Yes wonderful.
When people come together
that's how they come together
and create a family
a fellow
a feeling and I think that the gatherings
that the Bridge Alliance is
doing kind of start with that.
But then you can actually
get to these common grounds.
I thought to tell you something recently
that just happened.
I got a call from someone named Ro Khanna.
Anybody know?
He's a Democratic
representative in Silicon Valley
and in his constituency
is Facebook and Google
and Intel, Yahoo.
He told me half my constituency are Asian
and I'm Asian myself.
Democrat.
But I've made an alliance
with a Republican in Kentucky
whose constituency are
unemployed coal miners
and what Ro Khanna has
done is take a group
of coding trainers to
Paintsville, Kentucky,
set up a training program
promising that if you get
through the program you are promised
a 40,000 dollar a year job
and the first 30 graduates
of this training program
have graduated and you know
what they call themselves?
They call themselves Silicon Hollow.
So there are a lot of ways you
get family feeling together
these strips on particular issues
and then some actual imaginative ways
of handling real needs.
- There's the problem
of alternative facts.
- Alternative?
- Facts.
In California we have a
petrochemical industry
but we don't have to choke on the air
and the people who work in
that industry don't have
to live on eight dollar an hour wages
and the industry doesn't have to be
a historic polluter or
essentially a scofflaw
in every way, shape, and form
and we invite more regulation to make it
even more so and we
probably have more jobs
than they do in the
petrochemical belt in Louisiana.
They look at it and they
say keep the government out
otherwise it'll choke off our jobs.
We look at it and say make
sure we have the regulations
in order to ensure that
our jobs are consistent
with our life.
So we have a single item
of alternative fact.
I'm sure we could run
through almost every category
of governance, almost every
sociological category of data
and find that somewhere or another
on the ellipses or the
parentheses on the coast
we have circumstances
that are exactly opposite
to the circumstances in this area.
How do they live with the
fact that the way they are
doing it is producing an adverse result?
Huge unemployment, low
wage, bad education,
toxic environment, crap lifestyle
in every way, shape, and form
except that they can hunt
because they have multiple
guns easily available
and out here we've got
all of the rest of that
but on the good side of it.
How do they rationalize this disconnect?
And how do we get them to understand
that it's a factual disconnect?
- You know during World War
II my father-in-law had a job.
He was based in London.
He spoke German and he was a Colonel
and his job was to take Nazi officers
who believed in their own truth, right?
Fake news because Hitler was saying
oh London is in shambles.
Big Ben is in smithereens
and we're about to win.
And so what my father-in-law decided to do
was to take these military people,
put 'em in a car and go
to the center of London
and say well you can tell what time it is.
Look at Big Ben.
And what restaurant
would you like to eat in?
In other words, you
reveal a truth to a person
and then those officers
said you know what?
We're not gonna win.
We've been fed a pack of lies
and we're gonna help you.
So there are lots of ways to skin a cat
and one is not just how to
distance say you're stupid
you don't know this.
Come have a look.
Come have a look at California.
And when I got this tea
party Trump supporter
together with my son who is a member
of the California Energy Commission,
does this regulating and is
a ardent environmentalist
to talk about precisely this thing.
Hey you know we've got oil too
but we're not choking on it
and we're not dying from it.
You know what this tea party
Trump person's response was?
Hey that's not fair.
California gets to have it all.
That's not fair.
Well okay that's one of
these symbol stretch,
in this case a value stretch.
It's an opening for how to talk to people.
Thank you.
- Hi Arlie.
- Oh hey.
- Nice to see you.
So you inspired me to talk
to my ardent Trump supporter
nephew who I adore.
I thought that would really help.
I did end up cussing like a sailor
and we ended up back to
our love for each other.
The one place we came
together was where you said
about taking money out of politics.
So my question for you has
been I would love to hear
how you got over your own reactivity
which I imagine you have in listening.
So I'd find that very helpful.
- Well (laughs).
- [Woman] Reveal your
trade secrets please.
- You know I've written
about emotional labor
and this kind of research
I think requires it.
But actually it's interesting.
The job of listening was
to take my own political
and moral alarm system
off while I was listening
so that the purpose of my
being there was to learn.
I'll give you an example
of how that worked.
There was an evangelical minister's wife
who said at a meeting of Republican women
of southwest Louisiana
I love Rush Limbaugh.
You know the conservative radio host.
And I had a gag response to that at first
and then a thought, ooh
I'd really like to talk
to you about that.
And we went out for sweet
teas, what you do there,
and she said I love Rush Limbaugh
because he hates feminazis.
I thought I hope they haven't Googled me.
Second Shift.
And then environmental wackos and so on.
She went on and then she
was looking at my face
which I was trying to hold
neutrally and she said
is it hard for you?
I know you don't agree with me.
Cause I told her exactly who
I was and what I believed
or side I was on and I said
actually no, it's not hard.
That's not why I'm here.
I know about me.
But I don't know about
you and you're doing me
more of a favor than you know to open
your experiences to me
and I can't tell you
how I appreciate it.
You know what she said then?
Oh take your alarm system off.
I do that too.
I do it with my parishioners.
I do it with my kids.
And then we had that in common
and could kinda move from
there across vast differences.
She was the one who described heaven
as a cube of gold, you know?
So differences but yeah.
- Well what I get out of that
is the focus on understanding
as opposed to correcting or changing.
- Yes.
And you do wonderful work by the way.
- Thank you.
That was largely my question.
But I guess I also wanna
ask what else did you learn
about yourself in the process and ways
that you had to show up differently
or assumptions that you
had to check in the process
of hearing others' perspectives?
- Well people ask me
did it change my political beliefs?
And no, it didn't at all.
But did it change me?
Yes.
I would say it did
because now I walk around
with thinking how X or Y
you know Janice Serino or Mike Chef
would think about X or Y or Z
and sometimes it makes me sad to think
how they would see some things
here at our beloved Berkeley.
The Antifa violence, for example,
and their conclusion with that is whoa
your students they think
they're the students
or the fascists, you know, anyway.
So it made me more worried about us
and I see a kind of a defensiveness
and a non-openness on my side
that has me concerned and
has me wanting to work on it
and I'll tell you one thing.
Just two days ago I was
at the New Yorker festival
and got to speak with and hear
the Reverend William Barber
the Second the Moral Mondays
guy from South Carolina.
Very spellbinding and very incorporative
and he is really an heir I think
to Martin Luther King and his openness
and what he gets up and says
is I'm black, I'm white,
I'm Indian, I'm some ways conservative,
some ways progressive.
I'm all of these things
and I want to organize,
we are organizing in 30 cities
a big demonstration for poor
children across the country.
Hold the moral high ground.
The end of his speech it
was like a congregation.
A spellbinder thing and at the end of it
he had each person in the audience
turn to your neighbor and
say I will not be depressed.
I will not be depressed.
And then turn to them and
say I will get active.
I will get active.
And so I came home and
I thought you know what
I'm gonna write Carol Christ and see
if we can get this guy to Berkeley.
Incorporative, we need
to be incorporative.
- Hi, I am a young woman.
I'm a freshman at UC Berkeley undergrad.
I have grown up a military kid.
I've experienced all different places
and all different kinds of people
and as a young woman who's going to spend
the four years of Trump's
presidency at UC Berkeley
how do you suggest we go about
receiving our education and
going out into the world
finding a job in this kind of culture
that's been created and
this kind of like attitude
that's been created in this country?
How do you suggest we go about that?
- Well classroom education, dive in.
And as for your experience
here at Berkeley
take yourself as a builder of a culture,
of political discussion and debate.
At the moment I feel that
the Berkeley campus culture
of political debate reflects
the national culture.
You have a few polarizing
speakers that come in
in attack-defend mode.
You're either for them
or you're against them.
There is no middle ground.
It's kind of frozen.
You don't dare say what you really think.
That's a problem.
I think we need to really thicken up
and enrich the culture.
I think we need to bring theater into it.
We need satirists.
We need Reverend Barber.
People who have all kinds of projects
and I think there is an important place
for Berkeley Bridge.
So I would invite you to plunge
into that set of activities.
- Hi, thank you.
It seems pretty clear to me
that the kind of awareness
that you've demonstrated about
the deep story and climate
in Lake Charles has
definitely been perceived
and is in many ways used
by political campaigns
and news media to exacerbate the sets
of being hardly done by
and others getting ahead
so I guess my question is
when you were in Lake Charles
what is your sense of
people's ability to recognize
when they're being manipulated
and or any optimistic views
of how in Lake Charles the partisan divide
can be minimized or at least not inflamed?
- Well there are people there,
first of all, there are pockets
of progressives, of course,
in this conservative country and landscape
and they all have friends and relatives
who don't agree with them.
So actually they've gotten pretty good
at how to do this bridging thing.
Many of them just avoid differences
and keep their bonds without that.
They were as worried about
this divide as I was.
That was kind of the first
thing they would say.
I sort of came in like Mary Poppins.
Hi, I'm Arlie Hochschild,
sociologist at Berkeley
and you'll never remember my last name.
So jokes and then I would say I'm worried
about this growing divide
and that's the first thing they would say.
We are too.
We're feeling cut off and we don't feel
you understand us.
We feel you liberal coastal
people are looking down on us.
So you go write a book
and set 'em straight.
What they would say.
But you know what ultimately
I would love to see?
I think we need new
mechanisms, social mechanisms
for mixing up the American population.
We know that the 46%
of Americans who voted
for Donald Trump are
regionally distributed.
It's the south and it's the Midwest.
We know it's racially distributed.
More white, fewer people of color.
And class distributed.
Less likely to be highly educated whites
that are Democrats but much more likely
if they're high school educated or lower.
So given that kind of sociological divide
I think we need to look to mechanisms
that bridge those structural divides.
We used to have before
1973 a compulsory draft
which did that for men
and we used to have in its
heyday through the labor movement
labor unions used to do that for workers.
But we don't have either
of those mechanisms today
so I think it's on us
to invent new mechanisms
and what I would love to
see is either a one year
year of voluntary service
that kind of mixed
young people up or to have a program
through high schools and
to have in your junior year
coastal kids go inland.
Have southern kids go north.
Have norther kids go
south and for three weeks
be the guest in an exchange program.
So you don't send your
kid off to Italy or France
for their experience of the other world,
your national world.
What you do is introduce
them to the strangers
in their own country via this.
So not only I think we need two things.
These new mechanisms for mixing people up
and the result of that will
be to have new questioning
about what are true facts and fake facts?
I mean that's gonna
start some conversations
that aren't going on now.
So I think we need the new mechanisms
and then we all need to become mediators,
develop that skill set and
apply it in the new world
we wanna live in.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat instrumental music)